yes sir oh we have someone that's going
to force this way here we go this should
be interesting
150 dollars for pooping poop your butt
uh um I'm not sure I understand what
that means
Kentucky you're gonna give what you're
gonna you won 150 to pull you want to
give us 150 to put poop up your butt no
no please please stumble closer
what exactly did you mean and when did
and what order did you lose your job
family and children let me just tell you
something this is you in 30 years right
here right behind you to the casino to
the casino Taylor Hicks you sit the [__]
down you had your time and it was 15
years ago he's just doing the Macarena
you know that this 2 000 of us here we
will all remember this he will not
remember that yes 150 for poopy in my
butt what does it mean